(uplifting theme music)
- If you can find an eye
cream that actually has
that peachy pigment, I like to dab it on.
And then what I'll do
is I'll wear this out.
Instead of concealer, I will go around
with this eye cream on and do you see?
The dark circle has disappeared
at least, I would say, 60, 70%.
Now I don't recommend putting
makeup on top of eye creams,
it can cuddle like cream
in a hot tomato sauce
and you don't want that.
So this on its own, not
only acts as a concealer,
brightening and lightening the effect
and look of a dark circle,
but it's also taming
the dark circle while you're wearing it.
It's sort of a perfect
alchemy of skincare as makeup.
And I love this, it's my tried and true.
Run out, grab one, experiment with it,
and tell me what you think.
I wanna talk today about
corrective beauty makeup.
So I'm gonna take our onyx
eyeliner from Flower Beauty.
And as you can see, one eye
is just lower than the other.
So this eye is more open
and this one is more closed.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put this
on the upper water line
and it's gonna open
my eye to match this one, check it out.
So not in even the lash line,
only the upper water line.
Pretty amazing, right?
Let's see after I put some
mascara on for the final look.
I'm done now and I feel like my eyes look
much more even than they did before.
Corrective eye makeup in our waterline
on the eye that's more closed.
I have five minutes to do my makeup.
Ready?
Ha!
Okay, the Supernova
Celestial Priming Whip.
Yes, please.
I'm gonna even out my skin
tone, give it a lavender hue,
which lavender and beige are not only
a gorgeous design color combination,
but it's actually gonna
even out my skin underneath.
Celestial Priming Whip, done.
Moisturizer on the lip.
I'm going to use the new Hollywood secret.
(makeup rattling)
Get Real foundation serum.
Don't forget to go up on the
ears and into the hairline
because none of us wanna
be that 16 year old
with a giant baseline.
Also do yourself a favor, wash your hands.
I'm gonna just demonstrate
and watch, if I didn't wash
my hands afterward, this is what happens.
The final touch.
I wanna lock it in.
(spray hissing)
Spray powder?
Yes, please.
Just in the oily T so I can
be dewy everywhere else.
(theme song music)